hi guys Rob here I'm gamespot's resident
half stone nerd and Blizzard has
revealed a brand new expansion for half
stone called whispers of the old gods
that's going to come out late april may
be a bit early May and they've revealed
eight new cards that coming out in this
expansion so I thought be a good idea if
we took a look at the cars see if they
were worth playing on it so c'thun it's
a ten manner 66 battle cry is deal
damage equal to this minions attack
randomly split among all enemies 10
manner 66 is obviously terrible but of
course it comes with a battle cry which
does random 6 damage across the board
and in fact to the hero as well it
reminds me a little bit of paladins
avenging wrath spell that's a six-man of
spell that does eight damage across the
board and to the hero no one plays that
card and the reason why no one plays
that card it's because it doesn't really
represent good value for money aight
damage 46 manner isn't that great value
the jury's still out on c'thun because
on its own right now as you play it
right now it's not very good but there's
other minions in the new expansion which
can buff him up okay so beckoner of evil
it's a two manner 23 and it's battle cry
is give your c'thun plus two plus two
wherever it is a beckoner of evil is you
know to manitou three as pretty good
baseline stats the most positive people
will say or actually it's a to manor 45
because of the plus you pasta too buff
to c'thun it's not that good obviously
because c'thun is you know you can only
play them on turn 10 it's gonna take a
while for that for that value to come
into play I think if you have a c'thun
deck if you're going to build your deck
if you're going to build your strategy
around c'thun I think this is a pretty
awesome country okay so the next one is
Twilight elder it's a 3 manner 34 and at
the end of your turn this minion will
give your c'thun +1 +1 wherever it is
this this one's a bit different it's not
Val crying it's not a death rattle it's
at the end of your turn c'thun will get
+1 +1 that means you have to deal with
this card pretty quickly that means it
be a focal point for your opponent's
attack it's kind of like a torn you're
basically saying to your opponent you
have to sort out this card right now so
I think it's going to be a really useful
card if you build your strategy around
c'thun again I don't know how viable
that strategy is but this could be a
potentially dangerous card okay so the
next one is the eater of Secrets a
four-man er24 and check out this battle
cry destroy all enemy secrets and gain
+1 +1 for each oh my goodness at this
one card is going to eliminate secrets
paladin and I really think that will
happen it's too powerful if your
opponent has secrets paladin and you
play this you've eliminated all those
secrets in one go and you've buffed a 4
manner two for two I know anything up to
like a 79 you can this you can make a
really powerful minion and destroy your
opponent's secrets you know half stone
needed a card that attached secrets this
one is amazing this one this is like one
of the best tech cards you're going to
get in half stone this card is going to
change quite a lot I think okay the next
one is polluted hoarder for manner for
to its death rattle is draw a card being
able to draw a card with a 2 manner
minion it's pretty good having the same
effect with a four-man a minion this is
kind of weak yeah when it is weak I
think this card sucks okay the next one
is the corrupted hill but it's a five
manner 66 and its death rattle is
restore 8 health to the enemy hero
you're giving your opponent 8 health as
soon as this minion dies I think priest
players are going to enjoy this because
at 10 for you can have an arc a nice old
priest and a 10-5 you can play this and
obviously the arc a nice old priest
reverses he'll effects so when this dies
when the corrupted Hilbert dies your
opponent loses eight health that's like
the only viable way to play this card
this minion I don't think this
represents great value for money but I
think priests will have a chance okay
the next one validated doomsayer it's a
five manner not seven but let me starve
its turn
it's attack it's seven I like this card
there's a lot about this that I like
first thing I like is that it's really
good stats really good baseline status
when you're attacking also it avoids big
game hunter and it does it in a really
unique way the trade-off is that your
opponent can start smashing into it at
turn 5 or 10 6 and then I'm going to
take a any damage after smashing into it
once it's on the board you're going to
have to focus all your attack on it in
that sense I think it's still a pretty
good cut okay stand against darkness
it's a five-man a spell you summon 511
silver han recruits it's a little bit
like muster for battle but you're
summoning five silver han recruits for
five manner rather than summoning three
silver hand recruits for three manner
but you don't get the lights justice
weapon 14 weapon that you do get with
must've about does that make this worse
yes but also know something five minions
45 manner can be really handy if for
example you have a knife juggler on
board or if for example you have a
Frostwolf warlord which is five manner
you know at turn 10 get your five silver
han recruits and then player Frostwolf
that's a lot of stats for 10 manner
basically so it does have synergy
potential I don't think people are going
to play it though I don't think people
are going to play it because muster for
bowel was opie because you have so much
control by turn three it was amazing
plus you had the immediacy of a weapon
this does not have that okay so that was
the first eight cards in the whispers of
the old gods expansion for half stone
the expansions coming out at late april
may be early May as new cards are
revealed will have more details and
videos for years check it out gamespot